Pakistan has summoned Iran's top
Diplomat in Islam Abad over what it
describes as an unprovoked violation of
its airspace tan fired a missile that
landed in Pakistan's beluchistan
Province killing at least two children
now Iran says it was targeting the
headquarters of jai Adel group it also
blames them for several targeted attacks
on security forces over the years well
let's get more on this from our Pakistan
correspondent Kamal Haida who joins us
from the capital Islamabad uh Kamal
attack by Iran on Pakistani soil the
diplomats have been summoned and one
wonders how far this will
escalate indeed that is a good question
actually just on Monday it is surprising
that both the pakistanis and the
Iranians held discussion in tan in which
they express concerned about armed
groups operating from afan soil saying
that it was a security threat to both
countries and now this attack happening
in pjur very close to the Iranian border
pakistanis of course are not happy this
is not the first time however that
Iranian drones have been involved a few
years ago Pakistan shot an Iranian drone
inside Pakistani territory and so there
is of course concern that Iran did not
take Pakistan into confidence although
both sides had agreed that they would
cooperate closely when it comes to
action against these groups because the
J Al Al Al adal as you mentioned this is
a group that sprang up from the jandola
group which was led by Malik regi Malik
REI was captured by the Iranians in 2010
he was then hanged in a prison in Teran
in uh 2010 also so indeed that group has
been blamed by the Iranians however the
pakistanis are saying that they were no
other casualties except children and
that this was a flagrant violation of
Pakistan's airspace and sovereignty
we'll come back to you Kamal as in when
that situation develops but thank you
Kamal hi to there for us in Islamabad
let's keep on message and speak to
zishan suad he's a security issues
specialist he's also the director of the
center for regional and Global
connectivity at Tad laab that's an
advisory Services firm focusing on
geopolitics and joins us from again the
Pakistani capital good to have you with
us Mr sadin on the program one wonders
will Pakistan respond and if so how
because escalation is a real worry right
now absolutely and we're seeing this
level of escalation spread very rapidly
across the Middle East reaching all the
way towards South Asia and in Pakistan
right now I think in Islamabad there's a
real sense of betrayal I mean the
relations between Iran and Pakistan uh
have historically always been delicate
at the best of times but there's been a
component of you know strategy and
cooperation in that relationship
Pakistan has also maintained in at the
international front that the sanctions
against Iran amount to Collective
punishment it is unfair to the millions
of people that reside inside of Iran and
therefore having this kind of a missile
attack or drone strike or the exact
details of which are are are clear uh
this kind of unilateral action bypassing
the many established diplomatic and
Military channels that do exist between
the two countries
is really being views viewed as As a
matter of you know great betrayal by
Iran and as Kamal also mentioned earlier
this particular group uh which has been
blamed to be operating uh inside of
Afghan soil Afghanistan it seems is not
one of the three countries that Iran has
struck out in the last 24 to 48 hours in
terms of of this group is it dangerous
for Iran to start flexing its Regional
muscles um it's playing a very dangerous
game is it it not at the moment when
it's opening another front when many
Western countries are already blaming it
for its support of Hezbollah in Lebanon
and the houthis in
Yemen absolutely and I think that's the
perplexing part of all this Iran faces
significant geopolitical and
international criticism for its
involvement and backing of groups both
in Lebanon and in Yemen and in the
middle of all that to open up this new
front is just unprecedented now we do
know that Iran has been quite upset
about the massive suicide bombing that
happened on January 3rd in Iran that
killed close to 80 people and the group
is Islamic State took responsibility for
it and it was it was thought that the
strikes Iran conducted yesterday in
Syria and Iraq were in direct
retaliation to that but then switching
Focus 24 hours later striking allegedly
a group inside of Pakistan is just a
very strange move it's almost as if uh
it's designed to pull Pakistan into a
conflict that Pakistan has been
observing deserving and commenting on
from afar but is not necessarily
directly a part of I will also remind
you so that drone strikes are not a new
phenomenon in Pakistan the Obama
Administration hundreds of drone strikes
were carried out inside Pakistani
territory but the difference between
then and now is that at that point in
time Pakistan was a Frontline Ally in
the US global war on terror and there
was some level of tacid agreement and
coordination between the two sides the
Pakistani security forces and NATO and
Isa and Afghanistan when these kinds of
drone strikes would happen this is
completely unprecedented and much like
those drone strike a complete
circumvention of international law as
well what our viewers perhaps won't be
so familiar with is the problem that
both Iran and Pakistan both have in that
region uh of their territory because
there is um a secessionist movement that
has been bubbling under for many decades
both uh on the tahran side the Iran side
of the border which is also a beluchi
speaking uh Community as well as the
baluchistan side of Pakistan I mean
apart from what's going on in Gaza this
is another element within that discourse
for groups that either don't like Islam
Abad or don't like
tan absolutely and that's the unifying
force the key thing about this
particular group which has been active
since 2013 is that it's both ethnic in
nature and that it is a Belo Insurgency
group on both sides of the Border as you
said but on top of all that it's also a
Sunni cist uh uh Group which means it's
very much opposed to tan and has a bit
of a bone to pick with Islamabad as well
the important thing to consider here
soil is that in the past we've seen one
of two things play out the first is uh
in the case of the balakot uh attacks
that India conducted inside of Pakistan
uh Pakistan then shot down an Indian
pilot that situation was then
successfully resolved of the pilot being
handed back within 72 hours over the
border and then on March 9th of last
year there was a nuclear capable missile
from India that landed inside of
Pakistan's territory to which Pakistan
also responded very responsibly and kept
its composure and decided not to
escalate matters more kinetically My
Hope Is that Pakistan will also show
some level of restraint as far as this
particular incident is concerned but the
fact of the matter is that the same
chief of the Army staff that currently
leads p son's Armed Forces was the DG of
the military when bico incident happened
and this kind of blatant aggression my
fear is that might not go unhan we'll
see what does happen though zishan
thanks so much for joining us from
Islamabad